what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for another Midnight Club
interview with the team behind the show
congratulations yet again thank you I
love love your show
um before we get into the details just a
fun question to start here if you as in
real you we're in the Midnight Club what
would your mug look like and what would
be in it
well I mean I'm obsessed with the donut
mug that Ruth had that's the best I have
one of those at home now um that's the
best mug but I think in reality my mug
would be something super nerdy I would
try to find something that had like a
video game controller for a handle or
something like that or just be a skull
I have an actual huge mug collection so
the ones that I rotate on regular one is
a mermaid one uh one is a doctor who one
one is a Bob Fosse one and the other one
is a thing that came in my baby's play
kit that says uh the days are long but
the years are short very good that's
great
that's hard to top I think mine would be
mine is I have a hand thrown mug that my
cousin made that would probably be the
one
um and odds are I would need some
whiskey that's fair enough I feel like
it's very appropriate for Fireside
storytelling
um I am obsessed with the flannah family
and the environment that you create on
set in addition to just pure talent with
the people that you're working with what
else do you need to see in a
collaborator to know that this person is
going to be a good addition to our
family
um that's a great question you know it's
so many different weird things I I think
we look very much for someone who is
having as much fun as we are that's
really important you know it's it's a
job but I think we recognize people who
are there kind of grown-up kids like we
are
um and so that that becomes really
important there's also a certain degree
of I mean they're like they want you
want them you want to be able to have a
beer with them you want to enjoy working
with them but there's also a kind of fit
thing because especially when Mike's
directing there's a specificity to the
way we plan and it some some actors do
better with that than others some
amazing actors probably wouldn't be a
great fit because you know Mike's like a
three take director for the most part
and if you're not like coming prepared
you know and ready it tends not to work
so well with the way that we plan our
shoots you want to add anything
um I like being a part of this family
thanks for having me guys
um all right I have to wind out with you
guys soon because you have somewhere to
go a very special panel to have tonight
so I'm gonna do it now I'm going to put
up the spoiler warning for anybody out
there who has not watched all of the
Midnight Club this is where you push
pause you go binge it and then you come
back and push play and it will start
right here all right first question I
wanted to ask and let you guys talk
about freely is which uh which scene in
the show changed the most from script to
screen
oh wow that's a great question that's a
terrific question
um script to screen uh we were pretty
good about shooting the scripts on this
one I think we did a pretty good job but
I do know that episode seven Anya
um there's a lot in there especially in
uh the Town Square where she's walking
by all the shops and things like that
um that initially on the page got crazy
we had stunts people flying through the
plate glass remember that like we had
all sorts of this kind of explosion of
action and like the car crash from a
five came back that turned out to be
more than we could kind of deliver so we
we found a simpler version of it but I
think that's the one that probably
changed the most for the the most part
that we're pretty yeah
just go for it and see what we can get
so we kind of knew that things would
probably
yeah I
I it's quite effective as is I love it
um I have to talk about the very ending
I guess Heather came in earlier and she
was telling me that she didn't find out
about Dr Stanton's real identity until
like a little while into the shoot so at
what point did you all figure out that
that's where her path was heading we had
that in the writer's room
um we didn't tell Heather initially she
was more interested in talking about the
early parts of the season and I wanted
to kind of make sure that her Baseline
on Stanton was done before we got into
stuff like that you don't want to have
that kind of change the way she'd
approach the scene but yeah that was one
of the big twists we were excited about
okay I I don't want to put you on this
one this year but are you willing to
each share your entire
inches after because the other thing I
was talking about with Heather and I
explained to you before we even started
recording was that interpretations can
be different that's very exciting and
that's a big part of the reason why your
shows in general often stay on my mind
well after watching it but you know you
could have a different feeling depending
on what day day you're having so are you
in a positive Stanton day or a nefarious
dancing day the the beauty of it is I
think both of those can survive easily
into the second season and if we get a
second season I don't want to spoil that
because we have the answer already we
have a great answer that we're ready to
show if we don't get a second season we
are going to put it all over Twitter and
everybody will be able to see what where
you had in mind
I really like the sound of that I want
to know but I'd rather you get a second
season oh us too at the same time but we
don't want to leave people hanging what
was it a different thought process
those other shows were very strictly
like one and done this time around was
it a completely different type of
collaboration with Netflix because you
knew you wanted to keep going this is
the first time we've ever designed
anything to be ongoing and it's strange
it's a whole new Vibe because you want
the season to wrap up and be satisfying
but you need to leave enough on the
field that people might want to come
back so that negotiation is tricky and
you know usually we're done with the
show we can talk about it it's in the
past with this one we have no idea if
it's going to come back or if we're
going to be doing more so it's all very
kind of suspenseful for us we get to
experience the tension for a change it's
fun so hopefully we were able to like
have some nice emotional Arts that you
know fulfill themselves but then you
know mythological stuff that's all yeah
I'll have to wait
I'll ask you one last question that you
probably won't answer but would season
two of The Midnight Club take place
immediately after the events of season
one or will there be some sort of time
Jump there would not be much of a time
Jump okay um for a lot of our characters
they don't have too much time for us to
burn so we would be coming in relatively
relatively tight I think to where we
left off I didn't have the heart to ask
if there was going to be a new cast and
that's why I praised it but that's the
thing though about this show is if it
does continue
um there will have to be a new cast and
they'll have to kind of come in one at a
time as people go can you hear him in
the show say how long they've been there
so the timetable kind of writes itself
so much like extra special
congratulations to all of you on finding
that Ensemble and your casting directors
too that is an exceptional group of
young Stars you have and I can't wait to
see more from them and all of you as
well thank you for swinging by and
congratulations on the Midnight Club
thank you so much